[Music]
do you hello welcome to friendly a new
kind of social network for you
are you ready to begin yes yes what is
your name my name is Eleni Vanessa how
old are you I am 16 years of age what
are some of your interests skateboard
basketball I love walking I like to read
comic books the dungeons dragons series
I play the ukulele I play the drums I
have a piano in my room but I'm not very
good what do you most people not know
about me no one at school knows I'm an
activist I am Swift I am powerful I
really really like healthy food and I
like cooking healthy foods I guess it's
a little bit weird I listen to ariana
grande and Taylor Swift I like their
music that I know that people would
probably call me gay I'm a Kay but yeah
I do listen to their music
cuz it's good
what is something that makes you
different when I'm at home alone I dance
by myself and like the error like making
choreograph the exodus is like saying
not to see what out okay honestly I like
watching some movement for little-kid TV
shows i watch Spongebob really would
like to be famous actors and youtuber
combined I have to color dials I don't
know if you see that my ears kind of
stick out and that makes me look a
little more like a fairy what if your
bad color I'm best at dancing and I work
really hard I have really really big
dreams and I am going to pursue that no
matter what now it's time to take a
picture for your public profile
[Music]
good news your profile is ready I have
found your school network preparing to
share your new profile with all of your
classmates oh dear don't share my
singing my music tastes take a different
picture different picture please take a
different one say a different one
one more one more I'm a sham I know you
stuff I don't want my classmates to know
what I think I'm best at why I don't
want people to think that I think I'm
really good at something why I don't
want to be judged my name is Alyssa my
name is Brady
I'm 8 years old I work at SeaWorld with
the killer whales I like to write books
playing minecraft about to eat fairytale
books because fairies are so beautiful I
can go as fast as a shoe sale sometimes
I tell myself Jackie you look fabulous
I love so and my classmate
hello Becca Falcon I play for this staff
[Music]
before I share it would you like to
change any part of your profile I would
like to change myself my personality to
adopter concern my profile share my
profile share my droid profile
[Music]
I was bullied one time
[Music]
girlfriend Oh sweetie I don't work to
have black hair and I don't want to have
dark skin I get scared of what other
people think of me
hi I'm Ava I was bullied in middle
school and part of high school I decided
that I was going to be like everyone
else and that's how I would avoid
bullying but it didn't work what work is
embracing everything about it's a good
and the bad and all of the imperfections
I wanted to write a book that would be
able to help every kid deal with their
bullying situation and build confidence
and be able to move them towards a life
that they would love and be proud of so
that's what I did
this book is filled with lots of things
that you can actually do right now to
get yourself through bullying and on to
a life that you can be really happy in
and proud of
[Music]
preparing to change your profile and you
sure you want to change who you are
hmm no I don't really like changing
myself you know like I think I'm good
I know I'm not perfect but I just like
like myself you know it's fine you can
share it then leave my profile as it is
please share my profile
[Music]